the Patriot air defense system is 40
years old but has constantly been
improved over the years and is designed
to protect vital cities and air bases
the latest version can detect incoming
cruise and ballistic missiles up to 150
kilometers away
the advanced Interceptor missiles once
launched in the right direction are then
able to guide themselves to hit oncoming
aircraft or missiles well that's the
idea anyway as records being patchy when
used during the Gulf War in 1991 the
failure rate was found afterwards to be
between 60 and 95 percent but it was
still sold to U.S allies in the Gulf
like Kuwait Saudi Arabia the UAE and
Qatar
who recently is 2017 the Saudi armed
forces were reporting regular failures
against Iranian design missiles launched
by houthi rebels in Yemen
despite these failures the information
received on these missiles has allowed
the manufacturers to improve the Patriot
into an effective air defense missile
system
this information will be especially
valuable as Russian missile inventories
run low in the war in Ukraine and Russia
increasingly relies on iranian-built
drones and short-range missiles will the
Patrick make a difference to the war
unlikely the USS few Patriot batteries
to spare and the cost to each missile
fired is four million dollars compared
with 250 000 for a Russian cruise
missile and 50 000 for an Iranian drone
the arrival of the Patriot is more about
showing political support for Ukraine
than it will be about defending the
country